[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is
paul today we're going to focus on a
language called
catalan catalan is a member of the
occitano romance branch
of the romance language family it's
mainly spoken in
and around catalonia an autonomous
community in spain
as well as in another autonomous
community the balearic islands
and also in the autonomous community of
valencia
but some people will definitely dispute
that many members of the valencian
community will
insist that they speak a separate
language called valencian
others including most linguists simply
consider valencian to be a collection of
catalan
[Music]
to dialects um
okay let's leave that issue aside for
now but in any case
in all three of those autonomous
communities catalan is co-official with
spanish
except in valencia where it's
co-official with spanish under the name
valencian
oh man this video just started and i've
already got a headache catalan is also
spoken in the tiny principality of
andorra
which is located in the pyrenees
mountains and is bordered by france to
the north and spain to the south
catalan is also spoken across the border
in france in the northern catalonia
region
catalan is closely related to occitan
which is spoken in areas of france
adjacent to northern catalonia
in the past catalan and occitan were
considered to be dialect groups of the
same language
but they're now widely considered to be
independent sister languages of the same
occitano romance branch
catalan is also spoken in the town of
algero in sardinia italy
catalan is spoken by over 10 million
people some of whom indisputably speak
it as a native language
and some of whom speak another language
at home usually spanish but are also
fluent in catalan and speak it at a
native level because of their
environment
it's the sixth most spoken romance
language after spanish portuguese
french italian and romanian it's also
the most spoken non-state language in
europe
meaning that it's the most spoken
language that's not an official language
at the national level
that's because it's not official at the
national level in spain even though
millions of people speak it
it's only official in andorra some
people want it to be the official
language of a new country called
catalonia that would be separate from
spain
uh tell you what you can just google it
history
like all romance languages catalan
developed from dialects of vulgar latin
in
areas that had been under the control of
the roman empire
the earliest form of aksitano romance
known as old occitan or old provencal
had developed by the 8th century and
later some of its varieties began to
diverge into old catalan
between the 10th and 14th centuries in
the 12th century
the county of barcelona a catalan county
formed a dynastic union with the kingdom
of aragon
forming the crown of aragon and other
catalan counties
formed the principality of catalonia
together with barcelona
bringing them into the crown the crown
of aragon expanded under the rule of
james the conqueror who brought valencia
and the balearic islands under the
crown's control and these became catalan
speaking areas
the political capital of the crown of
aragon was the city of zaragoza
in the kingdom of aragon but the de
facto economic and cultural centers were
barcelona and valencia
both catalan speaking cities by the 14th
and 15th centuries the crown of aragon
had greatly expanded to include corsica
sardinia sicily and naples and for a
brief time
athens and neopatras in present-day
greece
there was a large catalan commercial
presence throughout the mediterranean
region
and the catalan language became
widespread at least amongst the
commercial class
catalan was considered one of the great
languages of europe
but in 1479 the crown of aragon formed a
union with the crown of castile
and castilian today also known as just
spanish or espanol
began to grow in influence and catalan
began to decline in influence
during much of the period from the 16th
century to the 20th century
various laws were enacted that limited
the use of catalan
in official documents in publications in
administration
and in schools but since 1975 it has
been made co-official in catalonia
valencia and the balearic islands
and in catalonia schools are now
required to teach most subjects in
catalan
in valencia there's less instruction in
catalan known officially there as
valencian by the way but there are
current government efforts to increase
it
in the balearic islands at least 50
percent of the students schooling must
be conducted in catalan
though there are also programs that are
taught entirely in catalan all of the
catalan speaking autonomous areas of
spain are bilingual with catalan
speakers also being spanish speakers
so what's catalan like once you learn
one romance language you've already
taken a great step towards understanding
the others
if we look at a list of basic greetings
in catalan there will definitely be some
words that speakers of other romance
languages will recognize immediately
good morning or good day that sounds an
awful lot like portuguese bondia
and spanish buenos dias good afternoon
compare that with portuguese
in spanish buenas tardes good evening
or good night compare that with
portuguese
in spanish buenas noches and in italian
good night would be
to say bye you might say compare that to
portuguese
adeyosh. spanish adios
and french adieu and if you want to be
more formal you might say
compare that with french au revoir
now let's look at some catalan sentences
and examine some of the language's basic
features many of which are quite similar
to other romance languages but with some
differences of course
this means joseph is a good teacher all
giuseppe is a
professor word for word it's the joseph
is a good teacher this sentence follows
basically the same word order you would
find in other romance languages and in
english
with one difference the definite article
al before the name joseph
in catalan a definite article is used
before people's first names
and this is called the personal article
we'll come back to definite articles in
a minute
this whole sentence is masculine
singular like other romance languages
catalan nouns articles and adjectives
are inflected for grammatical gender
and number let's look at a similar
feminine sentence
isabelle is a good teacher la isabel is
professor feminine nouns generally end
in
a and the adjectives that modify them
are inflected with the feminine ending a
as well while masculine nouns generally
end in a consonant or an
o or i one other thing i want to point
out here is that the letter
r is silent in the final position in
catalan so this word
professor ends in a vowel sound
there are basically four definite
articles the singular forms are al
and la which change to le with an
apostrophe if the following word starts
with a vowel or an
h the plural forms are als and lus
for the personal article there are the
alternate forms
with an apostrophe before a vowel or an
h
the indefinite articles are un una uns
and the way articles work in catalan is
similar to in other romance languages
but the forms are different
of course and there are also some
dialectal differences in catalan
articles
another sentence this means
she always has lunch very late
word for word it's she always has lunch
very late one thing i'd like to point
out right off the bat
is this phrase moltar in spanish it
would be
muy in portuguese it would be
in italian it would be molto taradi
quite similar to the catalan phrase
but in the other languages words tend to
end in vowels especially in italian
words end in consonants much more often
in catalan
but also pay attention to the consonants
at the end of these words
here we see the simplification of final
consonant clusters
t is often not pronounced after another
consonant at the end of a word
especially in the combinations of lt rt
nt and st sometimes it may be pronounced
slightly or articulated but not released
and in final position the letter d is
pronounced as
t but similar to t it's often silent or
unreleased
after another consonant simplification
of final consonant clusters is a
prominent feature of catalan
but it does not always happen and it
varies depending on the dialect
the speaker in the samples speaks a
central catalan dialect
here we have a personal pronoun as the
subject of the sentence this is actually
not necessary
catalan is a pro-drop language meaning
that the subject pronoun can be dropped
because person and number
are clear from the verb conjugation like
other romance languages
catalan has two types of personal
pronouns strong pronouns
which are used as subject pronouns and
after prepositions
the only difference being in the first
person singular and there are weak
pronouns which are clitics
that are used for the direct or indirect
object catalan has more weak pronoun
forms than other major romance languages
just a note about this word dina in this
sentence it's pronounced as
veena because in catalan d is pronounced
as the soft
the sound between vowels even though the
d is in the initial position here it is
affected by the vowel at the end of the
previous word
dina is a regular verb meaning to have
lunch and here it's conjugated
in the third person singular for the
present tense
catalan has three categories of regular
verbs which are characterized by
different endings
verbs ending in ar also known as the
first conjugation
verbs ending in re or er the second
conjugation and verbs ending in i are
the third conjugation verbs in each
category have the same or similar
conjugations
another sentence this means
he gave me the money this morning
word for word is to me has given the
masculine plural money this morning the
first word m
is a weak pronoun which is used for the
indirect object here
this form of the pronoun m apostrophe
comes before vowels and the letter
h while before consonants it's m as in
e m notice that it comes before the verb
azunat
is the perfect form of the verb duna the
perfect form includes the auxiliary verb
ave followed by the past participle it's
used for events in the recent past
and events within time frames that are
connected to now
like this month or this year there are
parallel tenses in other romance
languages and catalan's system of verb
tenses in general is very similar to
other romance languages
do not is another example of a catalan
word ending in a consonant
where it would end with a vowel in other
romance languages in italian this would
be
donato and in spanish it would be donato
in romanian however it would be donat
next notice the masculine plural
definite article because the word for
money
dines is plural the word aquet
is similar to italian questa or spanish
and portuguese esta but notice that the
s
and t are pronounced differently the s
is silent and the t
is not released mati is similar to
italian matina or french
metal coming back to the weak pronouns
for a minute
what if we want to use a pronoun in
place of alstiness
the direct object in this case o meaning
it
must come after the indirect object weak
pronouns come
after the verb in the case of
imperatives at least positive
imperatives
gerunds and infinitives so the
imperative sentence give it to me
would be another sentence
this means he graduated two years ago
word for word it's
reflexive pronoun he graduated makes two
years remember that the subject pronoun
el is probably not necessary
let's look at the end of this sentence
first this phrase here
fathans shows the use of the verb fei
meaning to make
to tell how much time has passed since
an event happened
this is similar to how it would be
expressed in italian
is a past tense construction called the
paraphrastic past
that is unique to catalan it consists of
an auxiliary verb
related to but not identical to the
present tense of the verb
ana meaning to go followed by a verb in
the infinitive
the paraphrastic past is identical in
meaning to the simple past which is now
normally limited to literary use
note that the reflexive pronoun in a
different form can appear after the verb
instead
if it's an infinitive or an imperative
or gerund
so this could also be bagra duarsa and
the whole sentence could be
el bagrado this verb construction
is somewhat surprising to me because it
looks quite similar to the paraphrastic
future
using ana means he is going to graduate
with
va being the third person singular
present tense of ana
this paraphrastic future form is used
less in catalan than in some other
romance languages
probably because it resembles the
paraphrastic past
so instead the simple future can be used
he will graduate in catalan you
typically form the simple future tense
by adding a suffix to the infinitive
form
but for some irregular verbs there is a
different future stem not the infinitive
in general the way that catalan verbs
are conjugated is quite similar to other
romance languages
except that the exact forms are somewhat
different with western romance languages
in general
if you speak one or if you've studied
one then the other seems somewhat
familiar right off the bat
but on the other hand everything seems
somewhat different as well
there's some different vocabulary
different phonology some different
grammatical features
and sometimes things are just expressed
differently being previously unfamiliar
with catalan for the most part what
strikes me is that i notice features
that are similar to spanish
to french to italian to portuguese and
to romanian
but i would never confuse it with one of
those languages because it has its own
unique elements as well
the question of the day for speakers of
catalan what other romance languages do
you find closest to catalan
can you communicate with occitan
speakers easily or italian speakers etc
and for speakers of other romance
languages how familiar does catalan seem
to you
what differences stand out to you
special thanks to my friend pablo who
helped with the audio samples for this
video
he's from the catalonia region of spain
and he's fluent in catalan spanish
english japanese and i believe some
other languages too
and he's a brilliant guy in general if
you're studying spanish or if you want
to study spanish
i recommend you check out his channel
dreaming spanish where you can learn
spanish using
his unique approach to language learning
so check it out
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and
instagram and once again thank you to
all of my amazing patreon supporters
especially these ones because they are
the best patrons
in the world thank you for watching and
have a nice day
[Music]
you